[Music]
as a teacher what we're experiencing in
the classroom
is the phone situation students are
you know zoning out really fast after
two years three years of absolute
complete and total isolation that phone
has become their heartbeat
[Music]
yo yo what up what up this is john with
the dr john deloney's show so glad that
you're with us
we have a packed house and by packed out
there in the lobby i mean i think three
yeah it looks like three man they are
lining up out here from all over america
are y'all from all over america
look at that from all you don't even
have to
[Laughter]
bust it so glad that you're here all
three people here and all 11 listeners
we're so glad to have you if you want to
be on the show give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291 we talk about mental
health relationships your marriages your
boyfriend's girlfriend's school
whatever's going on in your heart and
mind the people that you work with
whatever's going on
or you can go to johndaloni.com
ask ask fill out the form and it goes to
kelly love to talk to you on the show we
got a packed show today so let's get
right to the calls let's go to kim
in columbus ohio what's up kim good
morning
good morning how are you good how are
you
i'm doing well thank you very cool so
what's up
well um i'm a teacher
and uh i have a situation that is
becoming growing every year but when i'm
working with a large group of students
i want to know what's the best way to
assess and address the student's anxiety
levels
should i immediately back down when they
push back
um great question yeah give me an
example when you say they push back what
does that mean
they will shut down they will no i'm not
doing it
i can't do it
those kinds of things and um i teach
a subject matter that is related to
their future it's for career in college
i teach business okay and so
oftentimes it's about presentations that
are verbal
sometimes it's about rapid response
sometimes it is
you know ways that make them feel
uncomfortable everybody does a little
bit but i have some students that the
level is just so high
they can't even do it
so have you gone through at the college
level we had to do this and i don't
remember doing it when i was a high
school teacher um but that's more of an
like i wasn't a good high school teacher
so i think that's probably more to it
but have you gone through pedagogically
and pulled apart
i'm trying to speak just say this in a
not a sound like an idiot
or sound like a nerd have you sat down
and said for this next section the goal
here is to learn how to be comfortable
being uncomfortable
and here is
what the business world looks like when
your boss walks by and says why are you
working on this and your heart starts
racing and you go to firefight and so
here's the skills we're attempting to
learn here and we're going to on ramp
into it have you have you pulled it
apart that way for them so they know why
they're engaging in these things
absolutely and you know trying to have
them understand the why behind it always
is important no matter what the
assignment is love it love it love it
okay
so there's a couple of things that i've
been successful with
at the working with students now these
are college students so again it's a
different population so extrapolate from
it what you will okay
um
i and i got actually got this from my
wife and she's uh
savant she's a genius working with
elementary school kids so we'll we'll
find you in the middle here yeah um is
i would pass out um note cards to my
college students
and i'd say write down on this thing
something you didn't get
something that
that i blew by and that you are going to
loop on for the rest of class something
that you're struggling with here's what
i was providing them i was providing him
a release valve like just think on top
of a machine
yeah
and um i ultimately moved to a folder
and this sounds so cheesy and lame it
was incredible it was a folder that
allowed them
to every class period how did you do one
out of three did you show up prepared
did you pay attention were you locked in
how did i do one out of three what's one
thing you learned what's one thing you
screwed up and we just had a folder and
they got to design the folder they had
to talk about why they designed the
folder the way they did in class
here's what i was trying to give them a
some autonomy
a i want to teach them you own the
learning process too with me this isn't
a one-way street
and i want to like in the college world
you're paying me a ton of money i want
to make sure not that i'm giving you
like that i'm this isn't entertainment
but you're paying me a lot of money to
teach you biology and if i'm not
communicating in a way that you get
biology when we're done
i need to be better at teaching this
because that's what we're that's the
transaction we're making here and so but
it gave them some autonomy and what i
ran into really fast
was it
they began to take ownership of i've got
a role to play here and so some of my
favorite ones was when someone would say
you had a two deloney
like you were kind of
but i didn't show up i didn't show up
prepared and so i'm going to right they
had to think about that for a second
here's where anxiety loops in
anxiety starts with i'm disconnected
right i don't my relationships are
screwed up i feel like i don't belong in
here right i don't feel like i'm alone
and i'm scared
or i'm in a situation where i can't
control what's what what what's going on
here and i can see situations especially
for high school and college kids in the
middle everybody
where it checks all three of those boxes
yeah and so how can i reconnect them how
can i make them feel safe
and how can i
give them some but not all control
because high school kids can't handle
all control that's why they're in school
right college kids can't surgeon like
students can't right so
and here's the other side of it
i am
i think we've done a
systemic massive injustice to young
people and to their families
by making it so hard to
give a student the grade they earned
that happens to be non-passing
you as a teacher know what it's like
when you fail a student or you didn't
fail you gave them a grade of f or now
it's if you give them an 88 it's the end
of time right
um it's just be the incentive is to just
give them a 90 and move on with our day
the incentive is to just give them a
seven it's not worth all of the other
meetings and the documentation and the
drama and the this and the fights and
the lawyers it's not worth it
and so now we have a group of students
who
don't understand i can't in good
conscience i'm being an unethical
citizen
if i communicate to the world via your
report card that you passed this course
right and so i think the other side of
it is accountability
and what i find is people often rise to
the level of that accountability what
does that mean that means a school has
to say from the principal down we fail
students here
yeah that's who we are and i don't know
any public schools i don't know any
private i don't any schools that are
doing that anymore it's just hard right
right right and when the students think
they can't then they can't
yeah that makes sense
it does and i've been a teacher for 25
years so
you've seen the shift right
i have and i've seen the level of
anxiety in our young people
continually rise i'm glad they have
words to put to it
but you know i guess i feel like i
really want to move them in the right
direction
it's not to
harm them it's to help them experience
things that they will experience in the
future so i appreciate that i got some
great suggestions here's a great gift if
you gave them
i just go back to note cards because
they're so cheap for all of us and
they're so inexpensive and it's giving
them a tool i still use a note card in
my personal life every day
if you gave them
a note card that said what's one thing
you're anxious about today write that
down
and pass it in to me or write in your
folders that you'll all have that you
carry around that you turn in at the end
of every class um and that's one thing i
would do they turn him in at every class
and i'd go through i'm going to take
time i don't have but it
ended up saving me time down the road
right
um but what's one thing you're anxious
about today and if it was
my mom comes home at 10 o'clock and i
don't get to go to bed until midnight
then i'm gonna pass that on to the
counselor if it's i don't make um i
don't do well in front of the class
then we're gonna i'm gonna have a
conversation about i don't know how to
say this kindly but you are gonna have
to work through that because that's a
cornerstone of this class it's getting
up in front of other people right so
anxiety for me in the classroom is a
context not an excuse
it gives me some
i need to provide safety and that's just
the new role of a teacher as much social
worker worker as they are
um
pedagogical communicator right
uh or or subject matter communicators
better way to say that um
how do i provide safety and belonging in
context and safety doesn't mean
everybody gets an a and everybody gets
to say what they want and everybody
feels warm and fuzzy safety means you
can fail and you're going to land
somewhere soft
right you're going to get up in front of
class and say something really
ridiculous and we're not going to
execute you for it that's safety right
and they may not have that in the
workforce they probably will not right
no usually not
um but being able to get that out now is
better than
experiencing it later when they could
freeze up well and you're teaching them
oh that's what this feels like and
here's what i can do about it
right there's a thing i can do shutting
down is not an option unless you want to
have no rent in the future if you want
to have no like that's not a thing so
what is it that you're going to bring to
the table here um right you i see up on
the board kelly wrote me a note up here
you've got two questions what's the
second one
i like talking to you you're making my
heart feel good
oh good
uh the second one is sort of as related
but i can tell you as a teacher what
we're experiencing in the classroom
is the phone situation has really gotten
tough
so you know my why i was in industry for
14 years before i became a teacher
and my whole why is hey i want to get
you ready for career it's college and
career but ultimately it's courier
and so what i want for you to do is to
learn the things that will give you that
advantage
but what my problem is students are
you know zoning out really fast the
phones are coming out they're watching
videos texting friends listening to
music
um they would rather do that than they
would you know me
and so you know i don't want to feel
rejected i don't want to take that
personally but it feels personal when i
work really hard you know i spend those
nights creating those lesson plans and
coming up with fun activities but
that phone is such a compelling
thing for them and it's the rule the
rule is not to happen the statement is
made at the beginning of class every
every day hey let's put our phones away
let's eyes up fret and let's listen
let's get into it
but you know what advice do you have um
for me that
i can
you know continue to
get that um
idea my my why um across them what it is
that i do what i do
i love that so
when it comes like i had an advantage in
this discussion because the last group
of students i was with was graduate
students that i was teaching
and yeah i would tell them if your phone
rings in class you've that's your choice
that you're choosing to leave class
you're out like just go right and so
that was that's in and they're all in
their 20s and 30s and so everybody's
grown up in adults and you can imagine
exactly the one time my phone rang in
class and the whole class was like
and so like that's that's different with
grad students with with 14 year olds or
15 year olds
um here's a way to reframe that for
teachers and it's not going to solve the
problem but it's a reframe
that phone
with exhausted
fried burned out
super anxious
super in debt parents
after two years three years of absolute
complete and total isolation
yes that phone
has become their heartbeat it is the it
is a cheap neurological hack it's not
real
but the drugs it gives their sweet
brains yeah it's everything so think of
it as somebody's climbing up on top of a
roof
and you see them and you're like hey i
built you an incredible ladder out of
steel
and they're crawling up something on
like pvc pipe and duct tape and they're
about to fall and break their neck
your impulse would be to climb up there
throw your ladder up and just yank
theirs out from under them
and what they're gonna it's gonna if you
take their phones away and this is awful
hear me say i know this is bad
i'm gonna send a 14 year old into fight
or flight they're done for the day
right
so here's what i'm gonna have to do as a
teacher number one i'm gonna have to
create some sort of environment that
makes it not welcoming that means i'm
going to i had to change how i taught
over 20 years
and i hated that because i thought i was
incredible i thought i was the greatest
teacher of all time
and
that means i had to chop things up in
smaller bite-sized pieces we would do a
piece of lecture and then i'd put them
in they had to work on something and
then they had to give to the class then
we're back to right instead of me just
lecturing for 45 minutes and they do the
homework at home right so i didn't try
to chop it up because that's where their
attention span is now
also i don't know what it looks like in
high school again every school is
different there's so much drama yeah all
over the country
is it possible to have a basket where
all the phones go in
and you put yours in first i know some
teachers that do that they don't do that
in this building
those phones are you know little mini
computers they're quite expensive
and uh to be able to completely
keep track of them is really impossible
so um
you know when it comes to test dates
they're pretty good about it though
they'll you know put it up in the front
but on a regular everyday basis it is
pretty scary for them to let go
of that one thing
so do you have can i i mean you sound
like i would love to have had you as a
business professor as a business teacher
do you have connectivity to
let me just say it this way here's
something i did in a course so one of my
courses was that i taught was
basically how to run a university okay
it was an administrative course
and the course out of the gate was
mostly
geared towards teaching administrative
theories here's the way you can run a
school here's another way you can run a
university here's another way
i taught that way for a few semesters
and then one semester i blew it up and
what i did was i called my friends one
was a college president one was a
was a college cfo of an entire system
i think had a billion dollar budget or
something something massive i a provost
i i called in people who actually do
these things
and i had them teach
part of the lesson at the beginning of
class
i broke up my students into small
universities and they were all like one
of you as a president want to use the
cfo one of the views of the provo chief
academy officer right
and then they had to sit in front of a
pres like so we talk about firing and
administrative stuff
then they had the president would walk
in and they had to fire a real college
president it was amazing
but then after class we got to talk
about here's why we just did that here's
what that looks like
and so by bringing in professionals i
don't know if you can do that in a high
school level but it was it changed
everything because the theory wasn't
just something in a book that they were
half asleep
it was
oh i just had to present a budget to
somebody who does
who does budgets for a living and she
just eviscerated us
appropriately right or she affirmed us i
feel so good here's why
um budgeting theories matter does that
make sense is there a way to bring in
people in your community and then
reverse engineer it
absolutely and the light bulbs going off
over my head so
that's fantastic i can see um we have a
lot of really great human resource
professionals who would love to come in
and explain to our young people about
why it's important to take control of
that compelling feeling about the phone
um in the workplace so i think that's a
great idea if you and i'm again i am
jumping into your classroom and you're
not even there but if i've got 30
students and i broke them up into
you know x number
six groups of five
and
they
are all running a business that has to
cash flow at the end of the semester
what i know here at work i've been hired
by two different executives who hated
public speaking
and they hired me as a mouthpiece like
you're the guy that's going to go out in
front and speak
right and they knew as a leader i need
to hire my
my weaknesses that's what that's what a
good leader does and so maybe they're
not going to be presenting every week or
all the time but they're going to be a
part of helping create the presentation
that you see what i'm saying so they're
creating the business world moving
forward i i think there's just some it's
both and it's these phones have taken
over and i have to understand it's a
lifeline for them and they shouldn't
have them and as a teacher i have to
recognize they do and as a teacher who
gets students an hour a day or three
hours a week or something like that
i can't fight their parents and their
home systems and their trauma and their
tragedy i can provide a safe place
where they can fail and land softly and
then i can reimagine how i teach so that
they can see applicability here's how
this is gonna actually work there's a
person that does it and here's why this
theory is important or here's why this
practice is important this way you gotta
speak up loud because that woman's gonna
look across the table you would say i'm
not giving you any money
and what a gift let me just say this kim
on behalf of all teachers everywhere you
are
you make my heart feel good that you're
figuring all this stuff out here's what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna give you a couple
things okay
i'm gonna send you
i'll send you five i'm gonna send you
five copies of redefining anxiety it's
really thin and i wrote it so that a
high school kid a college kid anybody
can read it and get it
and you can you can have it in your desk
drawer and if somebody's really
struggling you can hand it to them and
it does direct people towards counsel so
you might say you go see the counselor
they're gonna roll their eyes you can
say hey read this check this out that
might help the other thing um i wanna
give you is i'm gonna give you two
copies of my friend ken coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose
if you get a couple of students who are
thinking about man what would it look
like to do like find work with meaning
man what a great gift this book could be
to give to a student you can check it
out to them and it's pretty cool when a
teacher points at you and says hey i
believe in you i think strongly if you
here's this thing read it over the next
couple weeks and bring it back to me um
then i think that could
it's inspiring right and i don't know
it's a good bridge between a teacher and
a student so there's a couple things we
give you thank you for being so
wonderful you're so great and everybody
will be right back
[Music]
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care
we spend time energy money on everyone
else but when it comes to making time
for vacation for exercise for talking
with a mentor for sleep even going to
therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
today dr john daloni show listeners get
10 percent off their first month so
decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back as you all know
most of you know i work here at ramsey
solutions which was a company based on
dave's
commitment to teaching people how to not
um
not live life
in debt to live life free with the with
the reigns off to run and live and give
wildly and so
one of the things that we know is that
being a teacher is expensive to get the
degree it's expensive to do be a teacher
they're grinding it all day long and so
we've got ramsey education which is a
whole wing that teaches financial
principles for middle school high school
kids and into college too
but here's the thing
you work so hard teachers and you care
so much
and teachers have taught the foundations
and personal finance curriculum to
millions and millions and millions of
young people it's incredible april is
national finance financial literacy
month and we're going to celebrate
teachers with a giveaway a teacher
appreciation giveaway sponsored by the
borrowed future podcast the bard future
uh documentary
teachers can win cash we thought how can
we love you we're going gonna give you
cash
right up to five thousand dollars for a
couple of different teachers um a
thousand dollars a thousand dollar
across the
teacher so here's the deal teachers
don't miss out on this if you know and
love somebody who's a teacher sign them
up for this it's cash it's cash it's us
just saying we don't know you but we
love you because we know what you've
been going through go to
ramsaysolutions.comteacherramsiesolutions.comteacher
for a chance to win let's go to sarah in
san antonio hey sarah what's going on
hey john thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for calling thank you so
much what's up
so um
okay
um i guess i'll lead with the question
and then like
provide the context afterwards um hey
take a breath take a breath hello
okay
okay you're good you're good you're
saying so i'm i'm very concerned
i have a teenager
and i'm hearing a lot of negative
self-talk from a teenager a lot and i've
noticed
this come out um
he doesn't take could
shouldn't say criticism like just
straight up criticism but like
constructive criticism when i point out
room for improvement
um
even
he's very bold a very bold thinker very
binary like extreme
all-or-nothing kind of person
and it's beautiful in a lot of ways
because there's a lot of passion that
comes with that but if there's
one little struggle one little thing
that doesn't go the way that my child
thought um just kind of a crumble
like implosion
self-negative talk and um
i just
i don't know like it makes me worry that
i'm just like how do i help my child
to grow up to be this man that can
continue to learn continue to be a
teachable person
and be confident within themselves
and not be afraid to try new things
um
yeah
thank you i love your heart man thank
you so much for that question
um you've probably heard me ask this
question before and so
i'll ask it to you sure are you okay
with
can we have some hard like just honest
two people hanging out conversations is
that cool
yeah that's all right and i'm gonna ask
you a few questions that
you can choose to either take really
personally or you can i i'm these are
not directed at you these are just
context questions okay of course so
anytime i have this conversation with a
parent and i've had this a bunch okay so
i want you to know you're not alone this
is a common conversation
where where in your son's world would he
learn that this is the way where would
he learn perfectionism or where would he
learn
i need to get all of this right
okay
so
i've been really reflecting
that's an excellent question because
when he was like i mean i'm telling you
this started very
very young um most two-year-olds and
three-year-olds don't feel embarrassment
like you know you'll see like a little
girl like dancing you know at the part
like like they don't feel that social
embarrassment
but my child was like the one that felt
embarrassed if anybody pointed out
oh how cute or oh how funny he would
withdraw and he would become like
self-aware and insecure
very very early um okay can i can i
pause you there can i pause you there of
course okay so a common i'm not saying
this is you but a common reaction to
that when somebody points at a
cute kid in a playground
a kid withdrawals
that's their natural inclination to
withdraw whoa this is too much i'd want
to be around this person
and as a parent for i'll just speak to
myself
i've got a kid that's very similar
um i get embarrassed
because my first thought is like say
thank you like shake their hand what are
you doing and i get embarrassed because
i believe that they're withdrawing as a
reflection of my parenting
and who i am is wrapped up in this so
what do i do
i go to my so my child my son or my
daughter and i say
uh-uh no they just said hello you go
over there and shake this is the way we
do this
and what i didn't realize i was
communicating to my kid was how you feel
doesn't
matter what makes you and this is the
word feelings are overwrought and we
have a culture that's overrun with
feelings so we'll get there
what their body was telling them is this
is not safe
and i told them you ignore your body you
do this
and
the feeling that you just mentioned that
some kids i mean that most kids just
they act actually it's not accurate
the ones that are at the park do
or the ones that are at this particular
thing do
but lots and lots of kids prefer to back
away a little bit or they feel safer
around kids themselves
and so if we do this over time
what a kid begins to learn is a
disassociation between what their body
says is safe
and what everyone around them needs from
them
what am i supposed to be doing and so
they tune their their
radar to everybody else
to the point that and again i am just
spitballing here this with your kid okay
you could say like john none of this
happened within our house
but you come all come all the way full
circle and then all of a sudden
the child's like one wrong mistake sets
off they were not safe alarm
because the the full the full line here
is this
when a kid gets overwhelmed that's their
brain saying we're not safe here
and so where i'm gonna start is less
with what are the right things i need to
tell them so that they can just get oh
they okay you gotta d on a math quiz get
over it let's move on to the thing
their brain is saying i'm not safe
either i don't belong here i'm not safe
or i'm out of control i'm not stupid i'm
not smart enough for this
what i found with my own son and my own
daughter i was guilty and i've worked
really hard to take this language out is
when they got an a on a math test i
cheered like crazy
when i saw them really working super
super hard super hard super hard super
hard and then they didn't get a good
score on it they got a retake
i would say oh man well you'll get it
what i communicated to them was dad
loves me more when this is happening
than when this is happening
and so one of those becomes infinitely
more safe than the other
and so where i would look to start is
where negative self-talk is but negative
self-talk is often picked up in the home
that's that's just like uh
kids learn from how dad talks to himself
or how mom talks to herself and so if
there's a lot of that going on i look
around the ecosystem there um so take i
just threw a lot at you is any of that
resonating with you or are you like
you're kind of off man it doesn't hurt
my feelings no
no um i think
there is a lot of um
a lot of truth in what you said um i
um and in parts with the grade with the
grades and stuff i never really put too
much stock in the grades i always
focused on is there effort are you
learning something that type of thing um
but
and other aspects of you know when he
was growing i i did a lot of home school
with him when he was very very young and
i focused a lot on education i was a
stay-at-home mom
and i really enjoyed you know spending a
lot of time in the library with him
reading to him and
you know just having a lot of
conversations with him and talking with
him and teaching and teaching and
honestly i almost feel like i over
taught him like to the point where it
was like everything was like turning
into almost a lesson and i tried to keep
it as natural as possible and
and i over time i've kind of learned to
step away from that like now we just sit
around and watch marvel movies and we
just hang out and you know laugh about i
don't know whatever you know is going on
and um i've kind of learned to gravitate
away because i started to see that like
okay yes
i laid a foundation for him but we need
to bond you know oh i love it i love it
i love it yes it's both in right it's
it's there's academic knowledge and we
can turn everything into a lesson
and our kids learn when we turn
everything into a lesson
that the best way i can find love with
my parents is to be right about things
yeah and how do i undo
how do i
undo a lot of that internal
internalization that he's made of that
so it is a couple of beautiful ways to
unwind that and it's gonna take you're
playing a long game here okay
um and also let's not hold all the all
the blame on mom and dad he goes to
school in an ecosystem he lives in an
ecosystem that tells kids from
kindergarten if you don't get in the
right first grade class you're not going
to get in the right third grade class
and if you don't get in that class
you're going to go to a not go to
college and you're going to be a loser
in brooke for the rest of your life the
ecosystem he's in right
and
you can homeschool you can avoid it for
a while it eventually catches you and if
you go home school all the way through
and then you go to college or you don't
go to college and you just go straight
to the workforce you end up there if you
don't get to this job title by this so
that's the world he's inhabiting and
that's hard when his orientation towards
the people he loves the most is i gotta
be right
i gotta have the right answer to this
and there's a lesson everywhere where is
it where is it where is it where is it
so a couple of cool things you can do to
unwind it one you've heard me say a lot
get a
get a journal that you share with him
that goes back and forth it's going to
be a conversation with mom
okay and kids can often read and reread
and reread and reread things that when
we tell them they don't hear it
they're going to absorb it and adults do
that too but
having something that you put on his bed
and he's going to write before bed and
he's got to do it and then he's got to
drop it off on the counter when he goes
to school and sometimes he's just going
to write like today was good and you can
do the prompt the second thing is stay
on the line i'm going to send you all
three decks of the conversations with
humans
some of them are gonna be um there's one
for dating couples you're gonna have to
skip a chunk of those okay
otherwise you're gonna be making another
call to this show and i'm gonna have to
refer you to somebody with way more
credentials than me um
but here's what here's what we're
looking for
i want to give my like here's a question
i have in my in my car i spent seven or
eight years trying to teach my son why
old punk rock and why old hair metal was
the best
and what i realized was he didn't like
it he just didn't resonate with him but
he really loved 90s country to all of my
souls chagrin
and now i've started to say hey what
you're singing along to this song tell
me what's so great about it
and i don't give him an answer
and i say that is
fabulous phenomenal why do you why do
those words why does friends in low
places resonate with you
as a as a sixth grader because you don't
go to a bar you know like why is he's
like man it's the melody and it's this
so what i'm giving him i'm giving him
control back a little bit of the most
important thing i can give him which is
his thoughts and his feelings and his
actions
and so i'm going to ask him open-ended
questions in a non-threatening way that
the cool thing about this deck of cards
is
is it points but it's not me challenging
you with questions it's just hey this is
just an attack
and he gets to learn what's your
favorite movie and he's gonna say it and
you're gonna say my favorite movie is
this why he'll tell you why you tell
yours and he's gonna be able to go oh
man we have different answers to this
and both of us are right and we both
still love each other
you see what i'm saying so i'm not going
to attack the perfectionism i might if
it gets if it gets abusive if he starts
hurting himself or cutting or getting
angry right raging out i'm going to have
some direct interventions there right
and i do that with my own family
but broadly speaking i'm going to circle
all the way back i'm going to begin to
teach him that i love him regardless of
his answers
i'm going to teach him i'm going to
teach him hey i changed my mind on this
i used to think this and now i think
this
there is no greater gift you can give
your kid than saying the words i changed
my mind
yeah that's what i'm saying
so remember this one phrase behavior is
a language and when a kid is
dysregulated whether that's they're
yelling at themselves they're wild
because they're they got a 99.5
and they didn't get a hundred
um they are
they are
doing drugs whatever the thing that they
are doing is to cope with the fact that
they're dysregulated what they're saying
is my body is telling me i'm not safe
and that's the greatest gift a parent
can enter into that moment
writing things down
going first and connecting with a like
just open-ended questions about things
and relational let's like have a date a
son a husband i mean a son and mom date
we're gonna do that every two weeks
and he's gonna the older he gets he's
gonna roll his eyes out of the back of
his head oh my gosh
and you'd be like if you keep doing that
i'm gonna hold your hand the whole day
right we're gonna but we're gonna have
dates and then you know what he gets to
pick where we eat every time
and we're gonna let him slowly get some
control back some autonomy back and
you're gonna say that's not even my
favorite restaurant but that's for sure
where we're going and then you're gonna
find something good on the menu you're
gonna eat it you're gonna say that's
great you picked a good place this was
good i'm glad you picked this
we're gonna begin to teach him ah
i can breathe
my relationship with my mom and my dad
isn't based on right answers it's based
on they love me full stop period and now
i could rappel off the edge of that rock
and swing and do life all kind of wild
because they love me
moms and dads everything's not a lesson
but everything is about love we'll be
right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change save yourself the headache and
call churchill mortgage today at triple
eight loan two hundred trust me that's
triple eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
one five nine one in the miles consumer
access dot org equal housing lender 1749
mallory lane suite 100 brentwood
tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right let's take unimas let's go to
alicia gosh this is the second show in a
row with someone from oklahoma what's up
alicia
hello how are you good how are we doing
i'm doing pretty good hey the last
person i talked to from oklahoma did a
good job so i trust you i trust you okay
i'll try
too much pray all right so what's up
what's up
okay um so i have been in the military
for seven years um my fiance has been in
for four and we're kind of at this point
where i'm trying to to decide if i
should stay in the military for another
year and a half or
um
and get out or should i
like continue on and be separated for
from him for like
potentially two plus years
does that make sense yeah totally so
y'all y'all are
both in the service and you're getting
stationed
on opposite ends of the planet yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah so what do you want to do
um
i
i love the military um
like i said i've been in for seven years
i feel like it's
i think the only
thing i'm good at or maybe i've i've
done it like my
adult life so
i'm just very comfortable here yeah
there you go you just you saved yourself
like seven months of counseling just
there
you're good at a million things but
you're comfortable okay cool
yes i'm comfortable and so
i think it's like the unknown of getting
out but i also want to be with him and
i don't want to be like geographically
separated for over two years
right
so the word that keeps coming to mind is
unknown all across the board here
and you have to decide which unknown do
you want
do you want unknown of this boy
i'm just kidding that's awesome i'm glad
you found somebody do you want unknown
of
making a leap into what could be the
rest of your life relationship
and the unknown of not being in the
military or do you want the safety of i
know what's going to happen monday the
monday 11 years from now i know it's
gonna happen
oh
that's so tough
not really
well
i like the safety i really like the
safety and that's why i like him because
i feel really safe around him yeah but
you're not safe if he's
17 hours away
right yeah
is
do you feel safe around him or is the
idea of him safe
uh i feel safe around him okay because
sometimes people pack up and move across
the country because the idea of somebody
else the significant other felt good
but when i got next to them they it
wasn't them it was the idea of them and
the reality of them the unknown of them
was more
was heavier than
the
illusion i had earlier right but you're
telling me that no when i'm in this like
this
this guy may be it
yes yes can i ask you another weird
question yeah yes go for it um because
you've had a you've had a front row seat
to this is there any trepidation are you
nervous about being a military wife
yes it's just
i don't know i
we kind of have
certain perspectives of them um
good and bad and i just don't want to be
on the other side of it that was the
nicest we kind of have certain
perspectives
of them they're so good like they're
this uh
this like just group of gremlins running
around yeah man their life is so hard
right and but yes you've been on this
side of the fence for seven years
looking through the little hole in the
fence being like ugh
and now you're like oh no i'm gonna be
one of them
yeah
so have you sat down and had an honest
conversation about
with
a military wife about that that world
that life
um
no actually
you should probably do that
seems like a good idea
okay do you think
yeah it seems like you're stepping into
the unknown and what's cool about uh
what's
a good way to step into the unknown is
with data
okay and the best way to get data is to
sit down and be like hey i've talked
crap about you all for a long time
what's your life actually like
and you may have to have some egg on
your face and be like oh my gosh y'all's
life is not what i thought even though
we just thought you all got together and
taught crap about the people in service
you know just complaining about
it's actually pretty hard you know i
mean you'll have to you'll have to just
kind of be like i'm sorry about that by
the way as a guy who's had egg on his
face pretty much every day throughout
his life it's cool it's all right you
just say i'm sorry and then you do
better next time
okay do you want to do that do you like
this guy
i do
i do
what are you going to do when you get
out of the military
i don't know that's why i don't know i
you have something so long i mean i do
um
i would like to i would like to be a
police officer so that was like my
backup plan if i
didn't make the military a career
but i know that can be equally as
challenging
yeah that's a whole other adventure
um i wouldn't compare challenge but
that's a totally new adventure that
you'd probably be incredible at and do
both in and is super flexible right
precincts all over the country are
hiring police officers
so arizona tell you i'm not going to
tell you what to do i don't have that i
don't i don't have permission to speak
into that and be like i think you should
do this with us i don't know you i don't
know him i don't know your situation
i think you have a choice between
do i want the unknown do i want a new
adventure and i don't know what's behind
door number four i think i do
or do i want comfort and
routine
and i'm willing to forego a really great
relationship i'm ready to forego a brand
new career
for safety and comfort and i'm not going
to judge you either way i know how i've
chosen to live in various moments of my
history
but my life's different than yours so
what are you going to do
i think i'm gonna get out in a year and
a half
when you just said that out loud how
does it feel
um
terrifying
pretty terrifying but uh
relaxing at the same time yeah
i think it's good to i guess make a
decision
if you get out
and you go be a police officer and y'all
break up can you go back in
uh
yes but i think there's there would be
like a um
i think they give you a minimum of like
a certain amount of time that you can't
you have to wait so many months before
you can get back in gotcha i'm just
wondering if what that looks like
um
i'm gonna do two things i'm going to
send you a copy of my friend ken
coleman's paycheck to purpose book just
teach you like what do i want to do with
my life and what does purpose look like
and this is a bestseller it's a good
book and i'll just send it to you for
free okay
and um how long have you been with this
dude
um since 2020
oh y'all are covered lovers
because they covet daters but you're
covered lovers you're about to get out
of the military for this dude
so is this like is this you see a runway
here for y'all
uh
yes so we want to
like elope later this year
come down to nashville we'll do it here
on on campus at ramsey solutions do that
okay i'm sure that will go well
do what he loves dave so come on all
right so here's i'm gonna give y'all for
your about to be engaged gift i'm gonna
give you a uh your subscription to
ramsey plus if he's a dave fam and hook
you up okay
and here's what's gonna do for y'all
this is gonna be a way it's gonna be a
tool that y'all can use obviously it's
get out of debt and all that kind of
stuff it's got all the
the app and all the stuff but more than
that it's a
it's a conversation starter for two
people who are learning to be on the
same page together
and some people are married for 20 years
before they figure out how to get on the
same page and they got four kids and
they realize we're in a mess and then
some people like you are like let's do
this on the front end
and so as you say i think i'm going to
transition to something else
i'm going to get out of something that
is highly regimented that's run pretty
much every minute of my life for the
last almost decade
that's terrifying i'm going to start
something completely new i'm going to do
it with this guy oh this guy does he
have tattoos everywhere
he does not oh he doesn't get him some
come on i'm just kidding
um i'm gonna this non-tattooed up guy
who's probably wonderful he's the
extraordinary guy i'm we're gonna start
practicing this stuff together and we're
gonna have some conversations about hey
how do you do money how did you grow up
with money how do you grow up what do
you think the role of a military wife is
or military are we going to move for my
we're going to do it's going to give you
all a
a
runway to what could be a lifelong
awesome marriage
thank you so much for giving up
everything so my family can put her
around and do our life i'm grateful for
you alicia thank you so much and thanks
to that boyfriend of yours he must be
something special if you're going to
give that up
and
um always remember this there's a
there's a there's a map back if you go
out into the unknown and you realize you
made a big mistake there's a map back
okay
this isn't an all or nothing situation
cool
cool i'm grateful for you good luck have
fun let me know when you when you put in
your resignation and you say hey i'm a
year out
um
and he proposes will you let me know
i will oh so cool you're the best you're
the best you're the best hey we'll be
right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now's your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
johndaloni.com to start creating the
life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
the booth brought me these lyrics i
actually love this song
on behalf of my
heartbeat that or the other half of my
heart that beats out into the world my
son
song's for you my man garth brooks
friends in low places and it goes like
this
blame it all on my roots i showed up in
boots and ruined your black tie affair
the last one to know the last one to
show i was the last one you thought
you'd see there and i saw the surprise
that the fear is his eyes as they took
his glass of not champagne son your
middle school glass of
water with bubbles in it and i toasted
you said honey we may be through you'll
never hear me complain cause i got
friends in low places
where the chocolate milk drowns and the
uh
cereal chases my blues away and i'll be
okay
not big on social graces think i'll slip
on down to the oasis
i've got friends in low places and we
all have friends of the little places
right here on the dr john delaney she'll
see you next time stay in school don't
do drugs
coming up on the next episode how did
your brother scare you he would like
literally push us down and like get in
our face and like pin us down
and like wouldn't let us go your older
brother is supposed to be your pathway
through life right
supposed to clear the deck for his baby
sister